[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتميز سلطنه عمان بالاحتفاظ بثلاث وجبات
خلال شهر رمضان وهي وجبه الافطار والعشاء
وجبه السحور وكذا نقول اللهم لك صمت الا
رزقك
[موسيقى]
الاستعدادات جميله جدا من الاسره وخاصه
نساء الاسره لانه يتم اعداد اواني خاصه
بالمائده الرمضانيه وايضا مواد غذائيه
خاصه بالمائده العمانيه حتى يتسنى افراد
الاسره انهم يكون عندهم طاقه استكمال
يومهم كامل بعد السحور وجبات السحور فتحصل
دائما الاسره عندها مثلا طاقم معين جزء
معين سوق معين لاخذ هذه المواد الغذائيه
الاساسيه لوجبات رمضان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المعده الرمضانيه في سلطنه عمان لها
نكهتها الخاصه بتعدد اصنافها الشعبيه
واولها القهوه العمانيه ومن اطباق
الرئيسيه في المعده العمانيه سلطه سمك
العوال والهريس والمكلايه مضروبه الرز
بالاضافه الى السمبوسه والقيمات وغيرها
تختلف اصناف المعده الرمضانيه من محافظه
الى
[موسيقى]
طبعا ايام رمضان مختلفه
ويستحب فيها التنوع في الطعام فتقدم كل
يوم وجبه مختلفه مثلا في اليوم الاول يقدم
فيه السوب اللي هو السوق حساء الحبه
الهريس مثلا اليوم الثاني يقدم الهريس
اليوم الثالث يقدم المقلاه اليوم الرابع
يقدم الشواء مع العيش عندك اليوم الخامس
يقدم طبق السمك مع العيش الابيض وكذا
بالتسلسل الايام لحد ما ينتهي ايام رمضان
[موسيقى]
تتميز وجبه الافطار المائده العمانيه
باللبن الطازج العماني وايضا بالقهوه
العمانيه وتتميز ايضا بالعصائر الطازجه
ومختلف العصائر حسب احتياجات الاسره وهي
توقف تواجد التمر في المائده اساسا بعد
الاذان حتى يستطيعوا انهم ايش ياكلوا
ويكون وجبه صحيه بعد الاذان المغرب
[موسيقى]